باتل الشعب الواقع تحت سياسه نظام قمعي
لسنوات كلمه ترجمتها الاحتجاجات الاخيره
التي شهدتها البلاد اما الكرسي يخامنئي
فلم يعد صلبا في الاصوات التي علت في
شوارع ايران احتجاجا على العنف والقمع
دفعته لاصدار عفو عن عشرات الالاف من
السجناء ومن العديد من المعتقلين في
الاحتجاجات الاخيره فيما افادت وسائل
الاعلام الرسميه بانه سيتم العفو عن
السجناء الذين لا يواجهون اتهامات بالتجسس
لصالح جهه اجنبيه او بوجود صله مباشره
تربطهم بعملاء في الخارج او بتعمد القتل
او التسبب في الاصابه او بالتسبب في دمار
واحراق ممتلكات الدوله او من لا يوجد مدعي
خاص في قضاياهم لكن بعد وقت قصير من اعلان
الافراج هذا عن الاف المعتقلين افادت
وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه بان السلطات
اعتقلت الصحفيه اليناز المحمدي والتي تعمل
في احدى المؤسسات الاعلاميه التابعه
للاصلاحيين دون توضيح سبب الاعتقال كما
اصدر القضاء عقوبه السجن سنه واحده بحق
الصحفي حسين يسدي الموقوف في اصفهان لتصل
قائمه الصحفيين المعتقلين على خلفيه
الاحتجاجات في ايران الى ثلاثين صحفيا